he's the ratings King now doing the
documentary thing you know who I'm
talking about
[Music]
Tucker smart as can be no one you will
see gets ratings like he and we know
Tucker Tucker nothing he won't do to
prove he's the one true king of TV
[Applause]
[Music]
oh that was so twisted
yeah the fearless and ageless guy you
know it's Tucker Carlson is a new Fox
Nation special coming out called the
death of Comedy which actually kind of
makes it weird that he decided to come
on my show to promote it welcome back to
the program Tucker how are you
you know I'm dimly dimly aware uh that
their like weight fluctuations in my
life but I never watch TV
Apple that video I'm like all right no
more pizza for me
um
did you enjoy that little uh uh thing we
we made for you I think you should
replace the opening of your show with
that that was a homage picture of me oh
God it makes me sick yeah hey here's
what we learned Greg actually that if
you were to offer up a program that was
actually funny and not terrified you
could probably beat the existing
offerings in late night comedy
um because there's that hole there it's
something that you should think about
yeah you know uh it's true and I'm kind
of worried that once they figure out I'm
out of a I'm out of a job I like the
fact that they haven't done that yet the
only funny person other than this or
funny thing other than us is is uh Don
Lemon
like he's truly true he's truly the
funniest person on television
it's like you're beating them because
you're better
okay you're inherently funny of like
native humor that's better than theirs
but you also just like aren't terrified
it's not a complicated formula like if
you're Stephen Colbert who is talented I
think I've always thought he was
talented and then you become like a
shill for Pfizer because you're so
afraid of getting yelled at by your wife
or whatever's going on in his personal
life and then you lose then like doesn't
it occur to you I'm humiliating myself
I'm being beaten by Greg Gutfeld like
maybe I should no but they can't because
they're in a fear spiral and you say
it's just wonderful to see you dominate
so the the the everything behind I'd say
cancel culture or this uh death of
Comedy is fear you think where I mean
I've always I've pretty much figured
that was the case but where do you see
the fear emanating from like what is it
what what is causing the fear you said
it could be the wife but what is it do
you think there's something larger going
on
well I mean there is this I mean not to
be theological but there's a spirit of
fear that's descended on the country you
know the levels of paranoia looking over
your shoulder checking yourself before
you speak I mean they've all risen it's
no longer a free country on the most
basic level in other words people don't
feel free
um and that's really what matters so
there's that and anyone who's willing to
say what he really thinks and observe
reality as he sees it and not filter it
through some sort of you know internal
propaganda machine that person has to
make a conscious effort not to be afraid
I mean you deal with this every single
day of course and but but you you beat
it like you push down those feelings of
fear and conquer them and then you win
and so I guess that's kind of what
shocked me is why aren't more people
doing it right is is the fear like so
overwhelming that they they're they're
willing to like destroy their careers
you find yourself like making a joke
defending Joe Biden you're just sucking
up to power don't you hate yourself you
have what they do you have
um comedians on your special also you
have Jim Norton yeah
what's it
was it hard to get people to even talk
to you because you know we have we this
show has a hard time and I've talked to
Adam Carolla about this that like
they're comedians that would love this
show but then miraculous like so for
some reason they cancel and you know
it's an agent or a PR person or whoever
a significant other
you know that's and that's totally right
and it's not it's not just you know the
middle-aged unhappy Rich lady wives who
are putting this pressure on comedians
it really is their managers and agents
and the people who you know gatekeep
throughout the entertainment business of
course on the other hand like success
in itself justifies I think
what they could do if they weren't
terrified in other words like if your
agent's not going to support you then
get rid of your agent yeah you don't
need an agent actually there's it's it's
deeper than that and the problem really
is this loss of self-confidence and low
testosterone levels and like people are
totally convinced if they just obey
they'll get through it and what they
don't understand is that when this
finally ends
they're gonna look at themselves in the
mirror and hate what they see and their
children won't respect them like there's
a huge cost to becoming a I mean
that's just true
foreign
for one question I I was thinking about
like uh what what were my favorite
comedies growing up and would they be
able to do it today and I was thinking
immediately of Animal House uh which is
I think the first real comedy I saw in a
movie theater was rated R I saw breasts
I'd never seen it before but I really I
think about that movie and I don't think
you could do that movie is there any
movies that you love that you know
couldn't be made now or even sitcoms
that's really I I haven't watched a
movie probably since Animal House I'm
just not a movie guy but I'm pretty sure
that the whole Otis he loves a scene
would be bad yes we just couldn't say
anything like that and of course it was
hilarious because it it was true like
comedy's only funny when it's true and
that's why when they Crush The Comedians
when they control the comedians like you
should be very worried it's not it's not
just like some neurotic guy you know on
a in a comedy club can't say exactly
what he wants it's much deeper than that
it means the people in charge won't
allow criticism of themselves and that's
to that's totalitarian so God bless you
for what you're doing that's really what
I learned thank you Tucker and it's Fox
Nation
is it available now
is available available right about now
yeah you just gotta figure out you know
Fox station which is super easy yeah
it's very easy Once I figure it out
there it is it's streaming now Tucker
thank you talk to you soon thank you hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else